Julian how did you become an activist
and do you consider yourself to be an
activist today I became an activist
because someone asked me to join an
activist movement i was asked by a
fellow student in Atlanta at Morehouse
College to join the beginning of
Atlanta's participation in the sit-in
movement and he was so compelling I
couldn't say no to him and so I found
myself caught up in it and I've been
caught up with it ever since so yes I do
consider myself an activist today
perhaps a different kind of activism but
it's still activism for the same sorts
of causes although the causes have grown
but yes I am still an activist was that
an easy decision though I mean when you
say someone asked you to join the sit-in
we're talking about a sit-in movement in
Georgia in a period in which that was
not a safe thing to do well I knew the
possibility was that we'd get arrested I
knew getting arrested was likely to put
a mark on your forehead do not employ I
knew that the possibility was of some
harsh treatment at the hands of the
police or white bystanders but I also
knew that other people like myself young
people young black people and other
college campuses like mine had done this
and they had braved these possibilities
without turning back and I thought I
could do the same and I found something
someplace in me that made me do the same
and so even though there was some
hesitation I could overcome it when you
made those choices knowing who your
parents were and you could tell us who
the word I know who they are how did
they deal with the choices you were
making at that time as a young man my
parents were academics my father was the
had been the president of Lincoln
University in Pennsylvania and almost I
also been the president of Fort Valley
State College in Georgia and at the time
this occurred he was Dean of the School
of Education Atlanta University my
mother had been a classroom teacher and
later become a librarian librarians are
there people interest in education and
so the idea that I would risk my
education by getting arrested or by
dropping out of college was just awful
to them but at the same time they were
very supportive of the civil rights
movement and encouraged me to get
engaged in it and so torn between these
two
the things and followed my promise that
I would go back to school someday and
finish my degree which I did too they
acquiesced